a good movie title should be memorable
but they don't always have to make sense
on occasion filmmakers end up with
titles that are wildly and sometimes
hilariously inaccurate here's some movie
titles that lied straight to your face
The Lone Ranger and no iteration of the
Lone Ranger is the heroic cowboy
actually lonesome his sidekick Tonto is
always by his side as a character Tonto
is almost as famous as The Lone Ranger
in fact in the 2013 movie adaptation the
guy who played Tonto Johnny Depp even
earned Top Billing over the guy playing
The Lone Ranger
Armie Hammer Fargo the only seen in this
Coen Brothers classic that's actually
set in Fargo North Dakota is the one
where Jerry meets the two hitmen to set
up the kidnapping of his wife the rest
of the movie takes place in Minnesota
specifically in Brainerd
Brainerd yeah home of Paul Bunyan babe
the Blue Ox sure you could argue that
calling the movie Brainerd wouldn't be
as exciting and the meeting in Fargo
spirals out in all kinds of craziness
but it's still the equivalent of Gotham
taking place in Metropolis you'd think
that two seasons of the awesome Fargo TV
series would correct the location a bit
right wrong deluged most of the series
takes place in other towns throughout
Minnesota North Dakota and South Dakota
with Fargo visited only a few times
throughout the show you do know you're
ignored to kuduro Friday the 13th
the final chapter yes the fourth movie
in the Friday the 13th franchise is
indeed the final installment in the saga
of drowning victim turned Hakim a
swearing masked murderer Jason Voorhees
[Music]
Jason's reign of terror is we all
thought Friday the 13th part 4 was going
to be the final chapter when it came to
Jason but little did horror fans know
that there'd still be a Friday the 13th
part 5 a new beginning Friday the 13th
part 6 Jason lives Friday the 13th part
7 the new blood Friday the 13th part 8
Jason Takes Manhattan
Jason goes to hell the final Friday
Jason X the one where he goes to outer
space
the 2003 crossover Freddy vs. Jason and
the 2009 Friday the 13th reboot Batman
Forever
not quite forever the third big-screen
Batman movie obviously couldn't have an
infinite running time though this movie
certainly seems like it never ends
exactly but it did well enough at the
box office
generate a sequel Batman and Robin that
one was so poorly received that it
prevented the Batman franchise from
going on forever another Batman movie
wouldn't be made until almost a decade
later with Christopher Nolan's franchise
reboot Batman Begins The Karate Kid
everything about the 1984 original The
Karate Kid is unassailable including its
title although the 23 year old Ralph
Macchio stretched the definition of KITT
but in the 2010 remake starring Jaden
Smith it isn't about karate at all in
this version Jackie Chan teaches his
young charge kung fu' not karate
considering kung foo comes from China
and karate comes from Japan having a
movie where Chinese action star Jackie
Chan teaches kung fu to a boy living in
China and calling it the Karate Kid
is a downright lie Mission Impossible
aula Tom Cruise is top secret spy
missions Ethan Hunt turned out to be
pretty possible after all even if they
are pretty difficult viewers can tell
hunts missions aren't impossible thanks
to the existence of multiple sequels if
any of them really were impossible he
and his whole team would be dead
that was not easy but uh I did it
Jurassic Park yeah it takes place at
your ass apart
welcome to Alessi but it should really
be named Cretaceous party because nearly
all of the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park
actually date to the Cretaceous period
the Jurassic era came before the
Cretaceous by about 80 million years now
if they can only explain that to the
dinosaurs thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
inaccurate movie titles we missed